افادت مصادره للجزيره بان الاتصالات
المكثفه للوسطاء الهادفه لاحتواء الموقف
في غزه تعثرت بعد اصرار الطرف الفلسطينيه
على الزام اسرائيل بوقف سياسه الاغتيالات
واضفت المصادر وان هذه الاتصالات تشارك
فيها مصر وقطر والامم المتحده واكدت مصادر
الجزيره ان الوسطاء نقلوا الى حركه حماس
رساله مفادها ان اسرائيل مستعده للالتزام
بتهدئه وقد اجابت الفصائل الفلسطينيه
للوسطاء وفق مصادر الجزيره بان اسرائيل هي
من بدات العدوان وان عليها ان تتحمل
المسؤوليه
ونقلت مصادر الجزيره ان رئيس حركه حماس
اسماعيل هنيه والامين العام لحركه الجهاد
الاسلامي زياد نخاله يبحثان سويا تطورات
الوضع الميداني واتصالات الوسطاء من
جانبها قالت حركه المقاومه الاسلاميه حماس
ان رئيس المكتب السياسي للحركه
اسماعيلانيه تلقى اتصالات من مصر وقطر
والامم المتحده لبحث العدوان على غزه
واضافت الحركه ان هيئه ان هنيه اكد وحده
المقاومه موقفها وجاهزيتها الدائمه
للتعامل مع اي تبادل من الاحتلال